remember when TV networks basically took
the summer off Netflix would never do
that to you like every other month or
year round the streaming service will
refresh in July with an impressive batch
of original titles and blockbuster
movies let's start of the streaming
giant's own crop of films and series
friends from college life doesn't get
any easier after you were not
undergraduate degree in the comedy
series friends from college six college
pals reunite in their mid 40s and to
learn something no professor can teach
friendship and adulthood are way more
complicated than they realize it's the
middle of the week without doing drugs
matter my age not at our age well it's a
comedy the trailer shows that the series
will also have a strong emotional core
which isn't all that surprising friends
from college comes from creator nicholas
stoller the director of forgetting sarah
marshall and other comedies that have a
lot of hearts to go with the last stole
the directed all eight episodes of the
first season of friends from college
which drops July 14th Castlevania the
classic Nintendo ghoul whipping video
game has come a long way since its 8-bit
origins now for the first time ever the
horror inspired backstory of the
long-running game series will make its
way to TV loosely based on the 1989 game
Castlevania three Dracula's curse
Castlevania follows the last surviving
member of the disgraced Belmont clan on
his quest to save Eastern Europe from
the villainous Vlad the Impaler the
trailer looks scary good we'll find out
for sure when season 1 arrives on July
7th ozark in a stark departure from
Arrested Development
Jason Bateman takes the lead in Ozark a
dark drama from the same studio behind
house of cards
Bateman stars as an embattled father who
finds himself dangerously in debt to a
powerful and ruthless drug lord in an
attempt to escape he moves his wife
played by Laura Linney and their two
kids from the suburbs of Chicago to a
summer resort community in the Missouri
Ozarks Bateman also directs and
executive produces the series which
looks like breaking bad meets bloodline
that's an episode first season premieres
July 21st to the bone Lily Collins
started an unruly 20 year old anorexic
girl sent to a group home
the bone a bittersweet film Netflix
picked up at the Sundance Film Festival
earlier this year people say they love
you what what they mean is they love how
loving you makes them feel about
themself collins is already earning
acclaim for her performance she's joined
in the cast by Keanu Reeves and Lili
Taylor to the bone debuts July 14th
chasing coral if you're still on the
fence about climate change in is
potentially catastrophic effects this
critically acclaimed the documentary
wants to sway you the winner of this
year's audience award for documentaries
at the Sundance Film Festival chasing
coral sensors on the destruction of
coral reefs due to drastic changes in
the world's temperature look for the
dark when it premieres July 14 Ari
Shaffir double- a stand-up special from
comedian and podcast host Ari Shaffir
taped last November at cap city comedy
club in Austin Texas double- is a rare
two-parter the first hour-long
installment focuses on comedy about kids
while the second part will focus on the
life you can't have if you marry and
have kids both parts drop on July 18 and
speaking of comedians but the stand ups
Netflix has put an increased emphasis on
big-name comedy specials in recent years
and now the streaming service is shining
the spotlight on a batch of lesser-known
names the first season of the stand-ups
each of six half hour specials dedicated
to some of the brightest rising stars in
comedy check the series out on July 4th
the worst which thirteen-year-old
British actress Bella Ramsay stars in
the worst which the latest adaptation of
kill Murphy's hugely popular children's
book series from the 1970s Ramsey plays
Mildred Hubble a bumbling younger wicked
cattles Academy a school for magic
however she wasn't actually born into a
family of witches making her an outsider
originally airing on the BBC the first
season premieres on Netflix on July 21st
the incredible Jessica James a vehicle
for charming former Daily Show
correspondent Jessica Williams the
incredible Jessica James is a thoroughly
millennial romantic comedy about a young
aspiring playwright in New York City
who's still getting over a recent
breakup Netflix knows the movie after
a bidding war following the screening on
the first day of this year's Sundance
Film Festival the film will be ready for
streaming on July 28th new movies plenty
of great flicks at the streaming service
in July
including the well-received prequel
juggernaut Star Wars rogue one which
hits Netflix July 18th it doesn't get
more dramatic than Titanic James
Cameron's world conquering mega
blockbuster look for it July 1st but
don't watch it during your luxury cruise
on July 9th Netflix will add another
widely acclaimed but much smaller scale
drama 2016's Lion the oscar-nominated
true story of a man who uses Google
Earth to find his way back home after
being lost as a child if you're looking
for a laughs Christopher Guest hilarious
Dog Show mockumentary Best in Show is
available July 1st yeah we both have so
much in common we both love soup you
could also embrace Christmas in July
with Billy Bob Thornton in Bad Santa two
available July 8th with the kids out of
school Netflix is giving parents a lot
of classic options for some of you
inconsiderate arest 'real available July
1st
if the kids are craving a movie marathon
the first three films from the
prehistoric Land Before Time franchise
will also be available the same day
after the kids are asleep check out here
alone a zombie flick about a younger
woman who's forth too deep into the
woods after a mysterious epidemic wipes
out most of society it's also available
July 1st starting to like sex you can
also stream the void a sci-fi horror
film that follows a group of people
trapped in a hospital balling with
grotesque creatures if that's all a
little too frightening starting July 1st
you can try taking lives and underrated
2004 psychological thriller starring
Angelina Jolie and Ethan Hawke new TV if
you're craving a binge this summer you
could do a whole lot worse on the 3rd
season of The CW's iZombie about a young
zombie who needs brains to keep her true
self obey and to help the police solve
murders check it out July 1st
if brain munching murder mysteries just
aren't your thing new episodes of the
zombie free teen mystery thriller pretty
little liars hit the service on July
20th and
more of a basic-cable reality-show type
of injure season 4 of the car
customizing here to West Coast Customs
is available July 15 with more new
things to watch on Netflix we can almost
forgive them for dropping the first six
seasons of Futurama almost if anyone
needs me I'll be in the angry doll
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're loved too
[Music]
[Applause]